welcome to this video playing doctor
bulky and if I played him right no let's
see do I know this guy best places to be
he writes Belgrade's Berlin and Sofia
yeah can't really tell never been to
Sofia and Belgrade Berliners okay then
the nerve our sins have been there but
liked it I recently discovered that this
is not a bad move and I'd bt2 with this
idea okay he's just going back our way
it isn't this yes this there is exactly
this trick let's let's try that okay
he's not playing Queen B 6 after Quimby
six days Queen age 3 with a double
threat Quincy eight and nine takes g6
okay he didn't he didn't fall for that
I'm just taking the the bishop now okay
what now night the night on d 2 yeah
maybe go here he was attacking age too
okay he couldn't really take it but so
the night on d2 needs to be moved anyway
um I'm wondering okay this is not
important anymore if Bishop f4 was a
threat you see just playing 45 p.m.
maybe he is
okay if he goes 'if I've yeah I thought
Nigeria would be a good reply isn't this
a good reply okay let's let's do that if
he moves the night i'm going to take a
five and it cannot be captured because
of f7f 7's just week Quinn a 552 it's
not the problem and what is he doing now
I mean move like okay isn't there is six
now even though i had do that really
looks wrong it looks wrong to me mmm
he's 66 maybe f6
checking here and I see all he has this
check out this is something that I that
must be aware of ok let's go e6 yeah
mine f6 looks like the only only move
then probably not have some okay yeah
yep my development is not great really
not but now one night f7 is also quite
attacking lots of material Bishop before
check would be absolutely deadly if he
gets this in yeah I don't have I don't
see it okay now he's attacking f2 and
probably just III m on the ship is not
protected Tony III m well the nidus also
covering important squares like d6 you
cannot go 26 or anything or Queenie five
what a night
I only Bishop before checkout Queen a5
this kind of move this can really kill
me like just thinking night c4 move like
that but queen is 727 I have time to
maybe create several actually oh this
one okay maybe he will go to g1 ok I my
take anyway whatever you need to take
and now Queen takes probably and if i
take now here Queen g1 I can go to see
two check check ok
okay i still think it's okay Queen g1 I
guess and now um queen No
23 wow that feels like a real stunt
Quincy to does this check here that's
not really on well yeah that was really
starting to play with fire in this game
so they're very well deserved that I now
have to it have to be precise IAM and
maybe the computer at the end will time
it has nothing going on but it feels
very dangerous check in new one and I
don't see a continuation really night f2
does no real threat even I mean okay hbu
text the queen but if I move it there's
no threat nothing a substantial I think
and I'm threatening something like we
need to just covering everything
check
yeah at least not not a big choice here
okay time or next just the Queen nothing
better than a no night f2 no don't down
I can take you three now okay it's not
not terrible though the real thing is if
you just take the night it's not it's
not so clear like a more sound check
yeah but I feel I feel I'm coordinating
rookie one
yeah and I'm attacking you this is not
so easy to cover even
do I don't see a move I think I'm out of
the woods now yeah the the pony for it
stops the night and controls everything
I guess black resigned yeah it's it's
over now but i don't know i mean it was
very very hard it's okay let's let's
check it I mean I was really banking on
the fact that this just seemed wrong to
black he has a good has a good defense
actually Queen a5 check chad is I didn't
really appreciate that sets completely
okay I mean yeah it's it's still a game
not like a draw or something but this
helps black this is not good like this
that's dangerous for whitey and that
should not do that okay but what is this
no idea computer wants to play fo and
set on that tiered it gives f6 like I
like I suspected and then it wants to
play Knight f3 I was I was intending
this move just to hamper black side
development the computer however
assesses this is good for black yeah
maybe this Queen g1 counter check is is
so dangerous that's possible and while
this night is certainly a young
irritating black kids also a bit bit out
there hmm damn
don't know this is ok Bishop c5 equal a
computer wants to take with the pawn Wow
ok this is given as equal III oh that's
nice that's nice I didn't see the this
move now that the computer is giving
night takes f to look at this check this
is very nice yeah let's check I cannot
go here yeah with the Q point check
checkmate very nice so this is not on I
need to go somewhere else I go here
chattin g4 and this is chad draw if i go
here got this check check chance to the
draw so black has at least the draw
after 9 f 2 and this oh this is what's
knocked the e sub knows better 7 Wow
okay okay okay i understand this is this
is very strong because of this idea i
get the bish I get the get the night mmm
okay that's strong okay i was i was
taking it i was already falling behind
on the clock anyway 2 123 only move
check yum and now the computer wants to
play 95 immediately and gives white a
slide too hard touch how exactly 22
Chad's takes Bishop takes chat line
takes King c1 and now it wants to play
that
well now if he gets he gets the spawn
and then it's it's certainly a draw now
okay and until Jim it's still not clear
anything yeah this this is losing only
95 is losing Wow yeah very complicated
game I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching